good evening I'm Alexander rose the
director of the long now foundation i'm
going to give you just a quick overview
of an event that's coming up I think you
all got little flyers in your hands but
we have some new additions to it it's
called the mechanic crawl and this the
idea for this event came to me as I
started taking the ferry into San
Francisco and riding my bike this way
and I realized that San Francisco has
some of the most amazing mechanical
treasures that nobody ever gets to see
and put together a little walk here
we're partnering up with the
exploratorium as well as the maritime
Parks Association the Jeremiah O'Brien
and the USS pompe Nieto and the museum
echenique it's all walkable bikable
we're going to have secure bike parking
as well as car parking and the museum
echenique if you haven't been there it's
down at Fisherman's Wharf it has among
other things dan zelinsky's the
second-generation owner and proprietor
there has been collecting mechanicus
pretty much of the turn of the century
on forward including all the way up into
the 80s video games and that steam
powered motorcycle which is one of the
most amazing examples I'm going to see
if I can convince them to start it up
for the event the pomp anito which is
actually the thing that started this up
is it has on board the most complex
mechanical computer ever built and it's
that targeting control computer for the
torpedo system and they have renovated
it to full working order and nobody
knows about it it's up in the conning
tower nobody ever gets to see it and
these wonderful world war two geeks have
made it completely work and nobody ever
gets to appreciate it so they're going
to be giving demos of that all day the
up on the hyde street pier they're going
to have a hicks diesel engine as well as
the old lighthouse for now lens assembly
running and the Jeremiah O'Brien if you
haven't seen it has a three-story tall
game engine that runs and this is kind
of the penultimate steampunk item that
very few San Franciscans ever get to see
go they're going to have it running all
day and the exploratorium is going to
have special exhibits and docents
including explanations I'm hoping of the
wave organ if you haven't been out there
its way out on the point and that's
about it if you're a long now member you
get free you get in free if actually if
you're a member of any of these
organizations you get in free plus one
and we're also looking for more partners
I'm trying to get a contact with the San
Francisco Fire Department which has this
amazing pumped station over here as well
as their fireboats if anybody knows any
firemen let me know and you can pick up
your tickets or order them through our
website at mechanical org or com we also
have tickets out front and we also have
flyers which you can give out to your
friends